to throw something at you I think Joe
Biden said Mega Republicans right right
you know I think that's a very careless
statement because the thing you jump to
immediately is like for Trump right
versus I think
the in the in the charitable
interpretation that means a set of ideas
yeah my actually problem with with the
mega Republicans line from from Biden is
that he went on in the speech that he
made in in front of Independence Hall to
actually try and Define what it meant to
be American Republican who's a threat to
the Republic was the kind of language
that he was using and later on in the
speech he actually suggested well you
know there are moderate Republicans and
the moderate Republicans are people who
agree with me on like the inflation
reduction act it's like well that that
can't be the the dividing line between a
mega Republican and a moderate like a
moderate Republican somebody who agrees
with you that you got to name me like a
republican who disagrees with you fairly
strenuously but is not in this group of
threats to the Republic you make that
distinction we can have a fair
discussion about whether the idea of
election denial for example make
somebody you know a threat to
institutions that that's that's a that's
a conversation that we can have and then
we'll have to discuss how much power
they have you know what the actual
perspective is what delve into it but
you know I think that he was being over
Broad and sort of labeling all of his
political enemies under one rubric now
again in politics this stuff sort of
happens all the time I'm not going to
plead Clean Hands here because I'm sure
that I've been inexact
um but somebody what would be good in
that particular situation is for
somebody to sort of read them back the
quote and I'll let you know where I've
been inaccurate I'll try to do that